so or counter-terrorists win has to be
one of the most iconic lines in all of
counter-strike but what if this beloved
naming convention was doing more harm
than good
what if calling each side terrorists or
counter terrorists was holding us back
from bigger things
it's an old question should we change
terrorists and counter-terrorists to
attack in defense or red and blue or
criminals and police or whatever it's
also a question that people get pretty
heated about okay okay okay now before
you start blasting me on Twitter or
writing your 500 word comment below just
hear me out let's have a rational
discussion about this issue for 10
minutes please let's start with the
apparent problem here look we all love
csgo and most of us have no issue with
calling them terrorists or counter
terrorists but some people or more
accurately some giant corporations with
very powerful PR departments do these
giant corporations have giant bank
accounts to match and they could help
take the eSport we love to the next
level understand that it's not
necessarily about anyone being offended
here or about being politically correct
or about correlating video game violence
with real-life violence which I think we
all understand is [ __ ] it's about
this can we alleviate a sponsorship
problem a money problem in csgo by
making this change and if you think
there isn't a problem with the words
terrorists and counter-terrorists when
it comes to how corporations with deep
pockets look at our eSport well you're
wrong
look SK gaming one of the oldest eSports
organizations on the planet pulled out
of csgo entirely in 2018 all due to the
fact that some big-name sponsorships
with deep pockets didn't want anything
to do with the game we wanted to try
something new for the brand it's also
connected to the new brands that we're
working with especially with the
sponsors counter-strike is a is a more
problematic title than some people think
especially when it comes down to the
sponsorship market in in Central Europe
in Germany a lot of companies actually
have a problem with the game it's a 16
plus title and we have no problem in
working with and around it but for some
partners it is a sacrifice and they
might not want to do it now maybe some
of you from the US and Canada are
sitting here after that clip and saying
Germany sucks what is their problem well
it's not just the land of Volkswagen and
schnitzel the igl for vitality Alex told
me that in France as well there is a
serious problem selling CS something
will happen in the world like for
example in France where we have lots of
problems with contract because it's
terrorist against an Terrace and with
the bombings that happen in France
sponsors I want to go anywhere nice yes
so if this was to happen on a more
global scale CS is still terrorist
against anti terrorist you could I could
see a world where no one would want to
go near it because of that and they
would have to do a sequel where they
would change it to like I don't know
police against progress or whatever you
want to call it everyone's interested by
the stats that CS brings like the actual
the competition side of everything but
as soon as they hear terrorists against
anti terrorist as it not knowing
anywhere near one of the main counter
arguments that I keep seeing when it
comes to getting rid of terrorists and
counter-terrorists is the changing of
the DNA of CS the idea that we're
mutilating this thing that we love this
thing that has 20 years of history all
in the name of a few extra dollars that
today it's getting rid of terrorists and
counter-terrorists and tomorrow we're
planting birthday presents and shooting
paintball guns it's actually something
Anders bloom and I talked about a little
bit in Berlin for the major I think it
does make a difference if you start to
interfere but like the you know the
theme of it like yes we are we are
planting a bomb in a bomb site you know
it's like it fine like I could see how
it would be it would be you would feel
the sort of attempt to to steer the game
in a different direction if suddenly it
was something else where it was like you
know yeah I have to bring a briefcase in
and it has to stay there for a while and
then you like you like then he would be
like what are we doing here you know I
even though the the actual feature of it
would be exactly the same thing you know
it would still be it would still feel
odd you know and you know what this does
make a certain amount of sense I mean
realistically does this problem with
selling CS to mainstream sponsors just
boil down to the word terrorists isn't
the blood the violence the shooting the
guns everything that makes csgo csgo
the real problem
here well maybe but consider Rainbow six
siege it's a game with a very heavy
terrorist versus Counter Terrorist vibe
operators have realistic guns they kill
each other there's a bomb involved and a
lot of blood
the only difference really between the
two is in our six there's less overt
references to terrorist versus counter
terrorists that and I guess technically
the gameplay is like a counter-terrorist
simulation and at least when it comes to
France Alex told me that
Rainbow six doesn't suffer from the same
public perception problem that CS does
Rainbow six this problem is probably
more than the game itself and not being
as popular CS right now for them not
getting sponsors maybe but yeah no it's
definitely I think in France it's only
CSS no there are other potential
solutions here too if we really want to
keep terrorists versus counter
terrorists let's look at mixed martial
arts like csgo it has to some degree a
sponsorship problem due to the violent
nature of the sport but if you operate
under a pay-per-view model like say UFC
you don't have to appease those sponsors
who might be uncomfortable with the
violent nature of your eSport or your
sport and Anders made that exact same
comparison
I love the analogy that I that I also
try and bring up all the time to UFC I
watched a lot of UFC I think it's great
they've sold a huge amount of problems
there by putting everything behind a
pay-per-view wall and you can understand
why they have the same problem how do
they find sponsorships for the UFC you
have an octagon in which people are you
know quite literally bleeding on the
company logos that are sponsoring them
you're only gonna find like a handful of
sponsors that are in on that and maybe
the sponsors that are in on it even know
that they're not in sharp competition
with you know every company in the world
unlike soccer you know football or
whatever it is so maybe you can't
pressure them nearly as much you won't
get like the same amount of advertising
dollars out of even though the UFC's is
doing quite well as far as I know but
you you know and you can afford to have
a lot of us here overall because every
viewer is gonna be paying more or less
through through the pay-per-view thing
and obviously that's been tried in
eSports in the failed a number of times
but maybe that is one solution and maybe
especially for a game like Counter
Strike which again is sort of advertised
of sensitive for reasons that I can't
even really
but you know if we don't change
terrorists and counter-terrorists is
csgo yz4 it's going to die no obviously
not our growth will just be that much
more limited and we don't want to lose
our identity just because of growth but
honestly guys if you woke up tomorrow
and it was attack versus defense would
it really matter
yeah attackers and defenders find like I
you know if that is what it takes to
bring you know coca-cola or Nike or
whatever to say ah you know fine as long
as they don't say the word terrorist
then we're good to go
I think that's that's a that's such a
small sacrifice that I can't see why
that would even offend anybody or like
anyone would really be angry about it I
want to do some impressions if that's
okay like these impressions just because
I play a lot of Inferno so I know what
the CT sound like on a Ferno a lot let's
just say oh this is bandit country shoot
everything that moves middle bingo bango
Bungo good stuff mate middle oh you're
right on your right on give me yeah
middle